[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
hey what's up guys welcome back to
culture binge the wisecrack podcast
where we explore
all the interesting facets of the
contemporary cultural zeitgeist i am
michael joined as always by wisecracks
executive vice president of vegan fast
food options alec
and wisecrack researcher and reckless
world traveler serbia
how's everyone doing today hi
doing well great wow i'm sensing a lot
of uh
seasonal celebratory vibes on both ends
alec
do we have this right that you're headed
towards a winter wonderland situation in
your locale
yeah everyone's like are you preparing
for the blizzard i don't leave the house
don't know why they're asking me that
they're just bragging that they go
outside and [ __ ] i don't know
wow indoor alec folks um okay so we have
a lot to talk about today unless you
want to respond to the indoor alloy
comment
no okay i thought maybe i crossed the
line it was about to get fired live on
the podcast
um so a bunch of stuff to talk about
today we'll talk we'll talk a little bit
about some new announcements
that were made by disney last week um
favorite company friend of the show
um we'll talk a bit about virtual dating
we know a lot of you are doing it
um and then some censorship issues on
streaming services
uh but to get started we're gonna stick
with our all slabs no chaps because
we're still not there yet as a society
as a world as a culture we need some
positivity and not any more negativity
so serbia we'll start with you what is
your slap for
this week this week i've been really
enjoying the queen's gambit on netflix
it's a story about a chess prodigy and
it actually got me really excited about
chess
so i've been wanting to go down that
rabbit hole to learn more
are you historically a chess player is
this something that's been a part of
your life or are you now wanting to dip
your toes
into the into the board because of the
show neither
i don't think i'll play chess but i am
very interested in learning about
people's passions and chess just seems
like something that
um it's like a niche like
passion where it's like if you're really
good at it you're so good at it
and there's like a whole subculture so i
want to learn more but i don't plan to
play chess
alex you seemed like you would have had
a a i almost said checkered past as a
chess player which i guess is mixing
things here but
you seem like someone that could play
chess pretty well no
absolutely not wow wow yeah i often
think of chess as like a foreign
language where if you don't really get
into it by the time you're 13
you're you're never going to be that
good but maybe that's
unfair to think that's my suspicion and
i'm not going to try
so okay so serbia will be the lone chess
master
of the podcast that's fun um and maybe i
will watch that show at some point
uh alec do you have a slap for this this
week uh
this is probably late to the game but i
just discovered dairy girls which is on
netflix
it is so [ __ ] good great job uh that
my pitch to it is
it's basically like if always sunny in
philadelphia took place in northern
ireland during the troubles but instead
of like bar
owners they are catholic school girls
who do highly unethical things all the
time
for example faking miracles to get out
of an exam but it's really [ __ ] good
i can also second that really good show
um
and i've never thought about it in terms
of always sunny so that's great it makes
me like it even better
um okay for mine um quick update just
because i
my my story last time around was about
um
sarah fuller this woman who became
became a football kicker at vanderbilt
university
uh made a field goal this week now
making her the first woman to score a
field goal
in a power five conference team so
that's fun i want to update on that
um my slap this time around i'm just
gonna go for a couple holiday movies
that i like that maybe are a little bit
under the radar
this will be our last episode before the
new year
um first i love the bill murray
christmas special on netflix i know a
lot of people hate
it but i am not one of those people i
think it has a nice depressing vibe and
i think christmas is low-key super
depressing and no one wants to talk
about it
and the thing i like about the bill
murray christmas special is it
acknowledges
the somber nature of the season but sort
of celebrates within that context so if
you are a melancholic
uh piece of crap like me uh watch the
bill merry christmas special
um the other one which is a very
different thing tonally which i hadn't
watched until recently it's a movie from
five years ago
the night before i'm starting
starts uh seth rogen joseph gordon
levitt anthony mackey
michael shannon it's a sort of night
before christmas tale of three friends
uh getting various types of inebriated
in new york city as they find themselves
and learn the true meanings of christmas
uh very funny and there's a scene in
particular where seth rogen
um while high on mushrooms runs out of
midnight mass at a catholic church
screaming we didn't kill him we didn't
do it
so i know so those are two maybe like
not as popular holiday movies i'd
recommend watching
um both with very different tones but i
like those
um but that's all i got i'll say i kind
of mentioned this before if everyone was
listening
this will be our last new episode of
2020.
um we'll leave some time for everyone to
to cry and gnash their teeth and whale
with that announcement we'll be back for
you at the start of 2021
but just so you don't get surprised when
in a couple weeks we do not pop up on
your feed
and as always before we get into uh
before we get into it
if you like us subscribe rate the
podcast
um you know maybe you can let us know
what you would get us for a holiday
present
uh if you were gonna gift for one of us
what you think we would want
um so you could leave that in your
review on itunes or spotify or stitcher
or any of those apps we'd really
appreciate it if you would do that think
of it as your
holiday gift to us subscribing
rating figure how to hack into it so you
can give us 11 stars
um now that said oh we'll get into the
topics right now and i'm going to start
this time um
and i'm going to take a big risk and
talk about disney related topics
so um every time we talk about it's a
home run everyone loves us nobody gets
mad
yeah in case you don't know this every
time we talk about disney we get in
trouble it's just a thing so this is a
cover me go i'm going in situation
and if you are a part of like the disney
gestapo and you're listening to this
right now
just hold on it's going to be good this
isn't to to trash on disney this isn't
to get negative but disney had a big day
last week on december 10th
they had an investor's day and one of
the main things that happened at this
investors day is they outlined
the next few years of their film and tv
output
everything they're working on everything
they have in the oven a lot of new
announcements
and in particular i think for us and for
our audience the two things that are
probably most interesting
were announcements made by lucasfilm and
all the star wars properties
and then the marvel properties so i'll
run through really quick some of the
things that are coming out
and then i have a small take on this and
i'm curious what you all think
so in terms of marvel these are the
shows we have coming to
disney plus in the next year or so we
have one division falcon in the winter
so
soldier i'll say it again falcon and the
winter soldier loki hawkeye what if
iron heart armor wars and secret
invasion
all new series coming to disney plus
they're going to be stacked movie-wise
some big announcements black panther 2
still in production and they're not
going to recast uh t'challa played by
chadwick boseman rest in peace so that
was i think good news for a lot of
people because that could have felt
really icky and gross if they recast him
um ant-man three coming out and we'll
introduce the character called kang the
conqueror
maybe wisecrack made a video about this
maybe we didn't um doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness is coming out
which will tie into the wand division
and spider-man universes and they're
making a new fantastic
four so all of that's happening on the
marvel side on the lucasfilm side
we have some real heat going on um
so we have two mandalorian spin-offs um
ahsoka
and rangers of the new republic which
are going to take characters that are
already in our mandalorian universe
split off and they're going to have some
overlap pretty exciting
a show called star wars the bad batch
which is an animated series about a bad
batch of clones
andorra which is going to star rogue
ones diego luna the acolyte set in the
high republic
area helmed by leslie headland who is
the creator of russian doll
very interested in that one um obi-wan
with ewan mcgregor and
hayden christensen coming back to play
darth vader sounds like a bad decision
we'll see what happens
i i eagerly await to see how
i'm excited for it but only excited to
see i hope he does a great job
you might not and i'm excited to see
that possible train wreck yeah and to be
clear i'm
i'm like truly rooting for them i'm
rooting for hayden christensen i want it
to work out well
but i could see a lot of options where
it does not work
um we got a droid story where we're
gonna have c-3po r2d2
um and a new mystery lead lando
which is an event show they said and
what they didn't announce with the lando
calrissian series is if donald glover is
going to play lando again
um he's a busy guy i feel like if donald
glover's not going to be in it they
shouldn't make it but that's just me
and then visions and anime anthology
series
and then movies real quick we got rogue
squadron uh directed by patty jenkins
director of the upcoming wonder roman
1984
and i'd say the thing that i imagine
anyone that listens to our stuff and
likes us would be excited about
the untitled taiko watiti film so he's
getting to make a star wars movie i
gotta be honest
very excited about that one um he did
really good work
on the mandalorian season one so a lot
of stuff
and and one thing that stands out to me
is for 20 years
we had about eight hours of star wars
content not including the
the early 80s star wars christmas
special um
and now in in a matter of decades we're
going
to an era where in 2021 we might
legitimately have
hundreds of hours of star wars content
um so we're taking a big i won't say
great but a big leap forward
and and i don't know this made me think
about a few different things
one of them is that from a business
perspective and if anyone listens to
this podcast you know we're all business
people we all have
mbas in business um kirby does right
yeah
i know we don't i was just taking credit
for servies valor
okay so if you listen to this before you
know that one of us has business
expertise
and the other two very clearly do not
um i hope that's okay that i say that
about you a lot of business skills and
philosophy courses
yeah we know nothing that's why well
serbia's here for a number of reasons
but one of which she understands
diversity
how money works um wow that was real
let's leave that in and let everyone
stew in that um
but from a business perspective as a
person who's never taken a business
class
but has watched always sunny where
business comes up a lot
uh it seems like there's almost no
longer an incentive
for a company like disney um and you
know subsequently lucasfilm
to spend too much time you know
carefully putting together
one great film or one great film trilogy
when they could crank out
multiple streaming series and we think
back to the most recent star wars
trilogy
a lot of money a lot of effort went into
that and in a lot of ways it's kind of
considered a flop especially the two j.j
abrams films
um and when you can put a lot less money
time and effort into something like
let's say the mandalorian which i think
has done a lot better and at least the
star wars fans
that i meet up with at star wars fan
meetings tend to like that
a lot better than the most recent
trilogy
so it's setting up this world where i
wonder like is this the future
of things like star wars and lucasfilm
content
and to a lesser extent marvel content
that we're just going to get a ton of
online series
rather than these sort of tentpole films
now my optimistic read of this whole
thing and i'm mostly focusing on
lucasfilm here so if anyone's waiting
for marvel
hot takes i don't gotcha but something
that makes me feel good is with things
like the leslie headland
um being in charge of the acolyte one of
the new series it makes me think okay
maybe what lucasfilm is doing is giving
projects to filmmakers and creators they
really believe in
and letting them do their thing so with
like a leslie hedlund
obviously get dave filoni um and john
favreau with the mandalorian with taika
wati in his upcoming film project with
patty jenkins
and we're just gonna give really good
creators
a key to a part of the star wars
universe and say like make your thing
i feel kind of good about that and i
feel like that's a great
move away from this necessity to like
keep continuing the story that george
lucas came up with when he was like i
don't know in a camping trip by himself
in
so that's my my kind of like positive
read um however
i don't know i guess the other side of
it is
are they just gonna pump out tons of
crap because they know we're gonna watch
it no matter what i think many of us
have
a lower standard for what we'll watch
on streaming as opposed to what we'll
spend you know 18 for a movie ticket ads
you know it's a big quantity versus
quality thing
but even if they're gonna be crap and
this is this is maybe a little nihilist
to me to admit
i still like the idea that there's gonna
be a lot of stuff and there's gonna be a
lot of star wars content and a lot more
marvel content and then i can watch it
from my couch
um but i wonder if this is all too much
have we crossed some past something
where we're never gonna have quality
content anymore and it's gonna be all
about quantity and pushing out as much
[ __ ] as possible
i don't think correct me if i'm wrong
are either of y'all
big either lucasfilm or marvel heads
i like star wars a lot okay cool alec
where are you at with this stuff
i i i have the marvel movies that i i've
seen
many of the marvel movies and like some
more than like others and then star wars
again i've seen all the movies
i've watched the mandalorian i don't
have a special like affinity for it
uh except that like sometimes the movies
are good and sometimes they're trash
like all the prequels
except the last one which was pretty
good well so that's even better then as
people that don't have an irrational
obsession or commitment to this stuff
i mean what do you think when you hear
this announcement where disney is
literally gonna be throwing hundreds of
hours of new content at us
especially in star wars where we had
nothing for years now we're just gonna
have everything
um how does that hit y'all
i uh so i'm torn part of me is worried
about oversaturation but the other part
of me is just excited because
maybe there might be like a really great
series or it dives into a different area
of the universe or
canon that i never explored or even
thought to explore
so some of it i'm excited about but
i'm also concerned that
they'll just push out things because
like you said will watch anything and
they just want to make money
um so i'm always a proponent proponent
of more content but i want it to be high
quality content which i think with the
number of
of projects they're going to do i don't
think that's
likely to happen you don't think it's
likely
that it'll all be quality yeah
i i wonder from a business perspective
you know serbia said over saturation
and it's the sort of thing where you
know the law of diminishing returns
you know maybe if you make two movies
you can double your revenue but if you
make 10
each one becomes probably a little less
profitable especially as people can
watch it
and i'm sure there's conversations about
this that we
are not privy to and probably never will
be but
did they figure it out and they're like
this is the exact number of shows where
it's like we can sort of maximize that
or
is the business model like listen we're
going to throw like 15 things at the
wall and if like two of them
become very popular like that's the
economics we can work off that's like
kind of how bloom house works is they
make a bunch of very cheap stuff
and all the you know if a bunch of them
fail and some of them do really well
it's fine
obviously disney is pouring more money
into things than boom houses
so like is that their model and also i
think there's an interesting component
in that
maybe it's good to go away from temples
because when you have a tent pole
like the last jedi or the force awakens
everyone with these very very very
intense relationships to star wars can
therefore like be mad and be like you
ruined my favorite thing
it's a little hard to like have that
same rage when it's like i'm watching
the mandalorian plus one division plus
this other thing and like i don't like
one of them but two of them are cool and
so like there's less i think
corporate liability which i'm sure you
know the star wars executives have seen
like a lot of um so i think that's kind
of interesting but i guess
my real question is what does it mean to
be
star wars um you know as someone who's
much more invested in star trek which
i've said before
you know like gene roddenberry had a
vision a certain ethos to the show and
every show
slash movie allegedly binds himself to
that ethos or
strays from it and then we complain
about and stuff like that and i don't
really know
besides like the lore you know obviously
there's the force and there's tatooine
and all that stuff but like is there
is it really just like a backdrop where
tycho with td can tell any story he
wants
but like it's set on tatooine or
something and therefore like it's a star
wars movie
the same thing with like you know the
recent joker movie there was no
necessary really need for that to be
joker which is a story told in that
format so is that what they're going for
well yeah i think that's the interesting
question right because so i think the
the way the thing that might have
screwed up the recent trilogy to some
extent is this the necessity to
only follow the lineage of one story the
skywalker saga yeah
and i think rather than having a broader
world with like rules and structures
like you have in star trek
they've been so wedded to that i think
you know marvel has the advantage of
having
thousands of different comic story lines
from over the years to pull from that
all
already interact and have some sort of
consistency so it sounds like and i and
i heard this fact this is not reporting
on my end but on um
the watch podcast i heard one of the
hosts andy greenwald mention
that what disney had been doing recently
or lucasfilm has been having meetings
with different directors and writers
they like a lot
and saying to them like what are you
into like what story do you want to tell
and then figuring out ways for them to
do that within the broader star wars
universe
and in one sense i like that a lot
because we're we're prioritizing
storytelling
and vision over you know
uh commitment to a certain very specific
canon
and i guess what we're gonna have to see
is how well do these things work
the further they're disconnected from
the skywalker saga
you know um and can we get really far
from that story
and still have something interesting
that people want to see yeah and i think
taekwondo is a great example of that
because he took
marvel and made thor ragnarok which i
think is probably my favorite marvel
movie yeah it's because
he you know did a thing with the
universe that i thought was really cool
um and so i like that model but it
really comes down to like is it
interesting because they're sort of
subverting or bending the limitations of
what it is i mean
again as a star trek fan there was news
i don't know if this is gonna happen
that quentin tarantino is gonna direct a
star trek movie and i was just very
excited because like what the [ __ ] is he
gonna do with that
and as like a star trek fan he gets it
and even if he breaks all the rules and
whatever it's fine
um but yeah i don't know like
is star wars at its core like a western
which is like what the mandalorians do
like what is
i don't know well to get like kind of
hegelian for a quick second
uh you know i think the genius of what
what td did with thor ragnarok is
he did something different he broke from
a lot of the character development we
had with thor we changed him a little
bit we changed the tone of the universe
we opened up some possibilities
and then what marvel did is
reincorporated all of that
into the broader mcu canon
and it and made the films better because
of that what we've seen so far with star
wars is you know like ryan johnson does
something very different
in film number eight and rather than
incorporating that through some sort of
dialectical sublation
into our storytelling universe they
react against that aggressively and
create a sort of reactionary film
so what i'm going to wonder now is is is
and i guess it's uh kathleen kennedy was
at the home of lucasfilm
is she going to be able to be open to
incorporating let's say subversive
contradictory or trans
transgressive elements from that
universe into these new
uh projects and are they going to be
open to that and i think if they are
there's a chance that the star wars
universe could get a lot more
interesting than it has been but that's
the best case scenario
i'd be worried about the lack of
diversification in their content
like your entire like if we're looking
at it like a business
like your entire product line is focused
on one
one thing so if we have like star wars
fatigue then what does that happen
what happens to your product line so i
would be worried about that like you're
putting a lot of money
and effort and all of your planning for
the next
say four quarters is all on one thing
i don't know that i would feel
comfortable doing that
yeah yeah oh and the the only other
thing lucasfilm does have is they're
making another indiana jones movie
with harrison ford
he's 100 years old i think they're going
to kill him while they're making it and
i don't want that blood on my hands
um yeah i like serbia i think
star wars fatigue will probably start to
happen at some point i don't know when
it will be
maybe they're good i think fatigue
probably takes a long time to set in
we still haven't hit marvel fatigue or
have we and it's been like a decade
i'm so nervous for it because it's going
to happen and when i was looking through
all the new marvel films and shows it's
like at some point
they're gonna [ __ ] it up and that's and
that's not even their fault at some
point any
any band any filmmaker any playwright
any novelist you can your run can only
go for so long
so it's like at which point is it the
weird multiverse stuff they're leaning
into is that gonna [ __ ] it up
is returning to the fantastic four gonna
[ __ ] it up but they're going to do it
and and i hope it it takes as long as
possible because i enjoy that universe
um yeah oh and i guess the last thing
i'll say because this ties in
they are making i know everyone is
worried about this they're making a
guardians of the galaxy holiday special
that i think we're going to have for
christmas 2022.
so um if you've thought about giving up
the holiday traditions
know that there will be a i'm hoping a
groot musical
that somehow ties into your favorite
holiday stories so i guess we can hold
on
for that um and yeah before we wrap to
rare wrap up two just so everyone knows
we just talked for uh i think 16 minutes
about a disney related thing
with enthusiasm curiosity and optimism
so just remember that and don't try to
screw us on this anyone you know who you
are
but speaking of movies well
why historically have we gone to films
to go on dates
why is dating hard now we can't go to
the movies in most places because
they're not
open so serbia how are we supposed to
date now
so we're supposed to go on virtual dates
now and
i've been hearing a lot of stories about
virtual dates
and so for those of you who aren't
dating right now during the pandemic
here's some background info
if you meet someone on an app you may
not feel comfortable
seeing them in person so you'll schedule
some zoom or face time with them
and you'll get to know each other a bit
before meeting up in real life and one
of my best friends
went on a facetime date last week and
she had a great time
but i recently read a new york times
article that discussed
how people have a fantastic time on
virtual dates
but as soon as they meet in person that
spark fizzles
one couple in the article talked about
chatting for months and feeling like
they were in a relationship
i think they were separated like one was
in new york and one was in chicago at
the time because of the pandemic
so when they were finally co-located
uh they met up and they had
zero chemistry they felt there was no
attraction there was no compatibility
there was nothing
but when they were talking on the phone
or on
a zoom they felt like they knew the
person that there was intense chemistry
there was a lot of vulnerability
and they couldn't understand what had
happened after all these months
so jacqueline mendes a licensed marriage
and family therapist
and sex sex therapist explains it like
this she says
what's happening is when we meet someone
for the first time after video dating
there's some familiarity already we feel
we know this person but we really only
know the presentation of this person
video just gives us one view of someone
and there's a missing
element of energy of the physicality of
the person
so what ends up happening is that we
start developing a fantasy
based on the information we have and
this fantasy takes over
we start imagining what it's going to be
like when we finally meet and we start
feeding and nurturing this fantasy
and anne martin who is a behavioral
therapist expands on this idea and says
that
as a result of our visual cortex we're
very keen on movement
and when we see people in 2d we're not
getting the full picture
and we can be turned off by the way
someone moves walks
or even eats so
to help recreate an in-person react
interaction
in a virtual format so that you don't
have these
uh problems of of not feeling that
chemistry or that spark in person
you're supposed to show yourself fully
by standing up
and turning around to give the other
person a clear view of how you
look can you imagine what a psycho you'd
seem like you're like hey i know it's
weird
you've been having these video chats uh
can you just stand up and turn around
stand up baby turn around for daddy it's
so
creepy it's super weird so
uh real quick alec can you stand up and
sorry
yeah we need to give our our uh viewers
some
we need to give them another element of
who you
it are join patreon and we'll do spin
videos
so who suggests uh that you also try to
get to know
people um not just through conversation
and by question asking but by looking at
the books they read
or the clothes they're wearing and she
says that you can't just rely on
conversation
to know someone and build chemistry
because it doesn't give you those
missing elements
and this is super interesting to me
because i've always thought that
communication is the cornerstone of
chemistry
and for me i've
i've been in long distance relationships
so i've relied a lot on video
or phone and i haven't felt that way
like when you
meet in person you don't connect with
them so
this was super interesting to me and i'm
wondering
is it as simple as not seeing someone's
full body or the way they
gesture is is there something else like
is it about someone's personality or
um is there another reason why some
people
are able to con continue that chemistry
in person
i don't know what do you think i think
there's just like a tension between
ideality and materiality in terms of
dating
and if you meet someone in person it
could be maybe they're like
playing a little koi verbally but
physically they're a little flirtatious
or you can tell they're into you
or maybe the opposite or something like
that and it creates this like
interconnected dynamic where we have two
people but each person is sort of
this ideal version of themselves via
verbal communication
and also this physical version of
themselves and we have interactions on
all these different levels
but sometimes with digital stuff it
sounds like we're reducing it wholly to
like
this ideal thing so what happens is if
you meet up like
you're like okay i know this brain i
feel comfortable with this brain but
this body is a foreign object
and this body is is something other that
i don't feel comfortable with
and that almost has sounds to me a
little bit like kind of uncanny or
awkward
and i've had a few times in my life when
i was younger um believe it or not
where i would have you know flirtations
or something like that
that would go through text or email and
then you meet up with someone you're
like okay this is weird we don't really
know each other that well i feel
uncomfortable now what did i say
i need to destroy your phone and and i
think that that's just like uh
i think that i don't i just don't see a
way we can really truly
avoid that tension if we're going to
think of
human connectivity as something that's
both material and and sort of language
based
yeah in a way i feel like some of this
isn't new because
you know it used to be back in my day
you would
a lot of flirtation happen through like
aol instant messenger or whatever
um even if it was like you introduced to
a friend of a friend and you it's not
long long distance but like you meet up
a few weeks later
but i wonder if maybe the new thing is
with video it maybe gives you a false
sense of confidence because i think
for not everyone but like a lot of
people there's
a lot of like non-verbal things that
happen
in how we interact with each other and
so on video like a lot of that's clear
with facial expressions but like
your posture and you know other things
that some people are better or worse at
reading
i think goes into that and i don't think
that explains all of this why people
don't have it and i wonder if also
another part of it is
um you know someone looks a certain way
like in the little camera box but then
they see them in person like i'm not
attracted to that person so um
this is weird and i hate this uh but i
don't know i i think the the question
is very interesting um not in a dating
context but you know i've had to
have long-term working relationships
with people over video and then meet
them and it is always like a little
jarring like i thought jared was short
and he was not short
i don't i had coffee with michael burns
after talking him on a bunch of video
calls once
maybe he thinks i'm a complete weirdo in
person i don't know
you were taller than i thought you were
i said that alec and if for anyone
watching or listening to this alec
doesn't come across
as tall as he is but he's a tall guy um
so i'll just say that yeah serbia it'll
be if we ever meet
so everyone who's listening watching
serbian i've never met in real life
i feel like we're friends and i
understand her and we'd get along well
but maybe one day serbia and i mean in
real life and we're both
wildly uncomfortable yeah serbia would
definitely i think hate me i don't know
why
no i don't think so so i'm i'm alive
um i'm way cooler in person than i am on
on video i feel like very buttoned up
on video because i work online work
remotely and stuff so
um in person when people meet me they're
like oh [ __ ] like i didn't realize you
were like
kind of fun so i i'm very excited about
that the other thing is people think i'm
shorter than i am
i've been told that i present very tall
which i'm very excited about but then
when they meet me they're like damn
you're not that tall
and i feel like i'm a respectable height
i'm five five
i feel like it's a normal height i would
have guessed like five three i was gonna
guess five six
[Laughter]
well here we are wow yeah
but no but i think this is interesting
because it's it is weird right because i
think there have been times in my life
where and i'll say this more in like a
friendship way and this probably makes
me a weirdo or a nerd but i've made like
a good amount of friends
over like twitter and other social media
over the years just from connecting with
people whether it's from like
people that have similar academic or
cultural interest or whatever
and i've had times where you've
interacted with someone in a pure
digital space
and then you run into them someplace and
you meet up and within seconds it's like
oh great
um but i guess with like a friendship
there's less let's be honest there's no
like sexual tension
yeah and i never to like you know
whatever friend
i met at a conference after talking
about philosophy online there's never a
time where i late and i texted him just
like
thinking about you and what it would
feel like to be near you
what don't act like that's crazy
everyone who er everyone has sent some
message like that at some point you do
it you think it's a good idea and later
you're like what have i done
and it's weird voice and everything i
felt like i was
i was like what am i listening to
but no but i just think i guess that's
part of it too is just like the
yeah the and but here's what i wonder as
well and serbia you can maybe speak to
this because you mentioned being in
long-distance relationships
i think there's a difference too for
your long-distance relationships and
sorry if this is prying too much
these were these relationships that had
a foundational establishment
in the physical world but then were
primarily
like digital or long-distance so there
was some foundation of
of like being in the same way one of
them we
we did date in person and then we were
long distance because of circumstance
but the
my last relationship we were not we
had we were talking for i would say a
few months online and then we met in
person
and the chemistry was just as intense in
person as it was
over um video probably because i'm a lot
better looking in person
and a lot cooler so he was probably like
yeah i got her when she was looking
like a hot mess and if you know that
that's great like if you know
your stock is higher in person then like
be confident on this online stuff
because you're good to go but if it's
the opposite
under promise over deliver yes
that's what i do because that's the
thing too i feel like a lot of and i
don't want to speak
on a generation i'm not a part of but i
feel like a lot of dating culture maybe
for like gen z types does involve
sending pictures or like online
communication where you look maybe
hotter than you are in real life because
of all the touch-up apps and things like
that which
i know had back in the day and that's
the risk there like how do you ever live
up to that yeah i would just rather
yeah i'm not very photogenic so i don't
know why you would want to like
touch yourself up and then you see in
person it's not like you can walk around
with like an in-person filter all the
time
i'd rather do the opposite weed it out
like
in the beginning because i don't know
why
try to see that's when i online dated
for a bit that was my strategy i'm i
made my lead photo one that i thought
was fine
but not my best because i would rather
not have people
click on me um than have people click on
me and then when i show up they're like
oh i wanted to show up and have them be
like oh okay
and then start from there that's my
dating advice from someone who hasn't
actively dated in almost eight years
but uh but yeah definitely take it and
use it this is all making me wonder what
austin's dating profile strategy is
um but yes if you are in australia in
the sydney area you're on a dating app
and wisecrack host austin smith shows up
on any of those please screenshot and
let us know
or give us access to your account and
let us try to online date him and see
what happens
anyone who wins yeah good when i came
across jared on the dating app he looked
just as good
on the pictures as he did in person
there was like no difference i was like
how is this possible
he's a photogenic guy well he's super
photogenic it was amazing though i was
like
this is the only time i've ever been
like this is exactly what he looks like
um sorry god no it was going to be weird
you go
i was going to say for anyone who's uh
interested in exploring this problem of
video dating before meeting watch 90 day
fiance before the 90 days where people
try to marry people based solely on
video chatting them from other countries
i would rather just do letter writing
because that makes sense to me that back
in the day you would have these
long-term
romances over letters because then
there's no semblance of physicality it's
pure
ideal to each other though if you're
rich
i guess but that's like the you know the
archduke's courtesans
art department is painting someone i
don't know
yeah i just think it's a little
different um the question is then
um wait serbia this nevermind is too
personal i'm not going to say it sorry
everyone if you if you thought you knew
what i was going to ask i'm not going to
do it because i'm drawing limits
but this is one of those things that
later i would love to hear what any of
our
listeners and viewers are doing if you
are virtual dating i want to hear all
about it i'm so fascinated by this and
um
you know what i know what someone should
do and i saw one person do this a
comedian in la
was going on online dates and then
streaming them on instagram live so you
could like watch them
oh my god yeah i think someone should
start a service where it's like that but
you like they don't tell the person so
you can just tune in to different
online dates or like a whole streaming
service where all the channels are
different people
having virtual dates wow
that's like some weird truman oh is it
truman's show
yeah i don't know like truman show me
chat roulette meets big bro i don't know
it's a lot of problematic things
i bet friend of the show dr ben
uh computer scientist and dating
officiato would have some thoughts on
this so
so dr ben if you're listening we'd love
to hear your thoughts on virtual dates
shout out to the best yeah just a moment
too and if you if you don't know we're
talking about dr ben netflix show dating
around go back to the special episode we
had a full interview with them that guy
rules um okay so that said
um this has been a really fun
three-person virtual date um i've really
enjoyed getting to know all of you
and i can't wait to see you both in
person um and once we get off this call
you'll have to turn around
uh but let's let's move on if that's
okay we got a last topic to talk about
alec we know that something you love
more than anything is censorship
mostly government censorship but
occasionally corporate censorship so
um what's going down in the world of
corporations
censoring streaming content uh so
there's a new york times article
that was posted in our patreon discord
shout out to them and whoever posted it
shout out to the page
and then there was a lively discussion
but i thought it was a really
interesting discussion so i wanted to
talk about it with you all
uh but there's new york times article
about a
show uh that was being developed through
apple tv which i know
everyone's watching apple originals all
the time it is constantly you know puts
puts hbo max to shame it's bat and i'm
just kidding
so um there was a show called scraper
uh that was clearly about a company
called gawker media
gawker media was a blog that uh
did reporting of various kinds tech
reporting business reporting politics
reporting
um they kind of had this like down and
dirty vibe where they didn't
like have a lot of the like professional
buttoned
up-ness of you know places like the new
york times or something and so they
would do [ __ ] like uh
somebody i think was the iphone 4
somebody
lost their iphone 4 prototype before it
was out at a bar and someone stole it
and then
uh gawker didn't steal it but they
basically
got their hands on it were like yeah
we'll we'll dissect this prototype even
though other people might be like that's
not cool
um and they did like a lot of various
things of
that people disagree with maybe it's
good maybe it's bad
um one thing is they
speculated about tim cook the ceo of
apple who's now an openly gay man they
speculate about sexuality not in like a
necessarily
mean way but just speculating that the
long-time bachelor was you know
a gay man who was hiding it um they did
that with other people like peter thiel
who's a billionaire they did things like
released hulk hogan's sex tape
that he sued them for which eventually
uh burned the website to the ground they
were in so much debt they sold off and
now gawker doesn't exist but
gizmodo lifehack or jezebel are all part
of i don't know who they've been sold to
probably some hedge fund
but anyway people involved with gawker
saw this show idea
to the people at apple tv plus their
their streaming service
uh the idea was it was called scraper it
was loosely based off of gawker
and it was kind of surprising given that
they were constantly giving apple [ __ ]
in the past but whatever
um that is until tim cook again in
charge of apple found out and personally
killed the project um and so i think it
raises an interesting question of
first of all the article in the new york
times notes that
this kind of the ceo coming in to kill a
project
is not heard of it's kind of rare and
in the reporters reporting they had
never heard of a similar example other
streaming services
let's say jeff bezos coming in and like
telling the boys tv show that they
couldn't do x y and z
because it makes amazon look bad for
instance um
have not heard of similar things at
netflix with reed hastings
but the the question it raises is that
you know a lot of our streaming services
a lot of the content being made
basically boils down to like a handful
of people
tim cook being a lesser player jeff
bezos and amazon prime video
reed hastings and netflix whoever is in
charge of hulu
and you know editorial decisions get
made all the time
shows get picked up or don't get picked
up for not allowing to say disney values
or this or that or having too much
violence or not being a right fit
but what does it mean for tim cook to
come in and kill a show
about uh based on an outlet
that you know questioned him and they
did lots of things besides you know
outing him that was just you know
reporting on powerful people
and what does it mean to basically kill
a show because they
maybe expose the truth about you uh yeah
what do you all think
well i wonder if business school serbia
has any thoughts on this or if this is
like a thing in the corporate world
because the question i have is like
shouldn't there be a sort of separation
of powers where if you have a company
like
apple there shouldn't be a king at the
top who's able to like
make an absolute decision in their
content or whatever that there should be
like
a head of that department who can't just
be overruled by someone at the top like
i don't know is there
and sorry to derail things but i'm
wondering serbia is there any precedent
in the business world for those type of
things
no like the ceo is like he's in charge
so there are heads of different
departments but at the end of the day
if the ceo doesn't like something you
can't argue with that
i i will say though at like especially
news outlets there is
kind of that the owner or person in
charge is often
kind of has that relationship but there
is certain editorial independence that
happens at lots of places and so for
instance again this reporter notes this
like jeff bezos owns the washington post
the reporter asked around the you know
the people
you know involved with that and they
couldn't find an example of
uh jeff bezos killing a story at the
washington post because it made jeff
bezos look bad
uh similarly like jeff bezos
has not said hey you can't portray
e-commerce bad in your tv shows
and so you know i think the distinction
is sort of like
if tim cook as ceo is like listen here's
what apple we stand for here's the kind
of shows we make and that's sort of the
dictate we have
and then there's like an editorial
independence and doing that and if they
run a foul then tim cook gets involved
and i think that's a lot different than
like
swooping down outside of the regular
kind of
normal editorial oversight of stuff like
that if that makes sense
like there's a you know if if uh
somebody owns
gizmodo the editor-in-chief should
probably get the final say in most
editorial matters obviously the owner
could fire them for like repeatedly not
listening to them but there's a certain
kind of balance of powers that is at
least like implicit in a lot of
places uh and i think something similar
happened at one of the sports websites
you liked where they all rioted because
they they didn't abide by that
um what am i talking about splinter no
oh yeah yeah i wasn't what it was on oh
my god it's gonna really bother me right
now
oh dead spin dead spin yeah yeah
so i um i'm not surprised that this
happened
but what is interesting to me is so
when you work at a large corporation the
ceo
is so detached from what's going on in
the weeds
so he probably has no idea what the
lineup is
like he might have like general ideas
like general projects and things but
it's not like he's having like
regular calls every day about the
content that's upcoming content
so someone either went directly to him
and told him this is what's going on
or he happened to come across it some
way but
like from my experience working with
ceos and working in the business world
like
this is not surprising i don't think
it's strange at all that it was censored
i i mean i like the idea that jeff bezos
like doesn't
have doesn't like squash stories and
kill stories but
in my experience i've seen these sorts
of things happen so it's not
it's not like weird or strange to me at
all yeah i mean it's just so
fragile like that's what bums me out
like tim cook is
a multi-billionaire whatever with so
much power it's like
who cares someone's gonna make a tv show
about based off a company you didn't
like that's probably not gonna be that
huge you might not even go past pilot or
whatever
i just i think it's a it's a bad i'm
this is this is a shallow comment but
it's such a bad look
i think to not have the ability to let
something get made
that somehow ties into something you
don't like it's it shows a sort of
i don't know i i guess a lot of powerful
billionaire men are just trying to prove
something to themselves
but also it's such a such a bad
precedent as well as we as we move
towards an
era where fewer and fewer people own the
companies that make all the content
it's a real bad precedent well i don't i
mean i agree with that but i also think
if you look at it from his perspective
like this might have been a very
traumatic experience for him and how
much pain
that must have caused him for somebody
to question his sexuality when he wasn't
ready to discuss that
and now he's in a position where he can
like say no i don't want to talk about
this how many of us have wanted to
like say something to the people who
have traumatized us and hurt us and now
you can actually do that
but could there have been a way they
like talked about it publicly and there
was some sort of at least attempt at
discussion reconciliation whatever
rather than just
[ __ ] you shows cancelled i don't i don't
know and i don't know
i just don't know who and and i don't
know this but like
are the people who are making the show i
know one of the career uh
show owners is a guy named corey
jefferson who's worked on a bunch of
other really good shows
like was he the person who was the
editor or involved in that outing story
like yeah i don't know i i i just wonder
like
is there a way to be more potentially
more subtle about this that acknowledges
um harm and tension on both sides
without making it this either or but
you're absolutely right serbia
yeah and i think to serbie's point i i
think like
if if the people in charge of the
regular slate were like hey
like uh we really disagree with like
gawker's history of
outing people you know whether however
they justify it like we don't think it's
cool
uh whatever like again those are the
editorial decisions
and i think even like to your point
serbia tim cook
might be very sort of justifying that
but i think the icky thing to me is not
like this isn't like a
a small production studio where it's
like of course i'm not gonna work with
these [ __ ] who made fun of me three
years ago it's like
a major monolithic there's only a
handful of companies that like make 90
of the content situation and i think it
just sets a precedent to
like we could look at this example and
be like yeah like [ __ ] gawker because
they did x y and z
at the same time would we be cool like
let's say the issue at hand was gawker
uh got their tim cook's friend arrested
uh for doing something illegal and bad
um
and because tim cook is still angry
about his friend getting arrested is all
fake
but like you know he's gonna like at
what what point does like the personal
interest of like four or five or six
people
get to like dictate what is on tv and i
think i i think that's scary and like
again like i'm not like
oh how dare they cancel this gawker show
i think it's mostly like
the way in which it was and by the way
like the gawker show could easily get
sold somewhere else because
other people don't have these vendettas
but then maybe tim cook will
call you know netflix and all these
people because he has that kind of power
and be like you know they were mean to
me don't you dare buy it
the thing is like this is already
happening this is just one of the times
we've heard about it
like it happens not only in this
industry but in my industry multiple
industries
so i don't think that it sets a
precedent it it's already
be done
no i guess the difference would be in
like the content media world that's
different because at least
in the world of like content production
and and you know media there's often a
semblance even if it's
[ __ ] that there is some like
creative or editorial independence
um and there isn't someone who can just
like pull the cord on that
but maybe a lot of that is almost like a
cafe type thing anyways
yeah it's that like again i think it's
not the decision that was made it was
like the way it was made
if the people in charge of editorial at
apple tv
said hey we don't want to be involved in
that uh all right like
yeah i think there's a smarter way to go
about it like let them make the first
episode
and then find a way to be like after
blah blah we decided not to go forward
with it
and then everyone knows what you're
doing but at least you're like playing
it like oh
listen let's just what i learned in
business school was you just you lie
and you lie until you're at the top and
then you lie some more
um i did not go to business school okay
um well i think we're good there alec or
serbia any last thoughts
on the streaming service censorship
issue
no okay um well we'll see if the show
gets made by some other network and if
tim cook can kill it there which would
be impressive
um but now it's time to get into i don't
know one of my favorite things we do
which is the voicemails and emails part
of this and here's the thing everyone
this is not a one-way relationship or
interaction if you listen to the show or
watch this you are part of the community
you're part of a family and that means
you have a voice you have a say
so we want to hear from you and then we
can hear from you in two ways um well
three ways i'll get to the third one in
the second
number one two one three five three four
eight eight zero seven you call us you
leave a voicemail once again that's
213-534-8807
we love to hear your voices so call us
um the other way if you don't like
your voice if you don't want us to hear
your voice if you're precious about your
voice email us culturebinge
wisecrack.com that's culture binge at
wisecrack.co
third way figure out where we live come
to our houses at night
um now i think we have some voicemails
that get to start at this time and
am i right yeah i think the first one's
from anonymous about
i don't know the hacking group this is
going to be sick oh yeah yeah
hi wisecrack big fan of culture binge
and as well as all the wonderful content
on the channel
enjoy all the fun conversations and
humor from survey michael and alec
i wanted to call in to talk about the
topic of deadly tours from the latest
episode
and wanted to chime in in agreement with
serbia and say that i also tend to be a
little less cautious
when i'm traveling on vacation you know
despite checking citizen neighbors and
the next door app where i live every
single day and whenever we travel i feel
as if our
psychology is similar to an inverted
version of maslow's hierarchy of needs
we're on vacation for self-fulfillment
needs and esteem needs
and both of these tend to be front of
mind when we're traveling
and the idea of safety and physiological
needs probably
don't come um as front of mind i've
definitely skipped a meal or two or
gotten far less sleep and generally
being less aware of my surroundings
during vacation because i just want to
soak in as much as i can
um but then also the topic of invisible
versus visible dangers
with visible ones like the new zealand
volcano and the invisible ones like
proven 19
um i think earlier this year most of us
were woefully unprepared and un
informed at how dangerous this uh virus
could be
and now you know we know a little bit
better but even with
buyer beware traveler beware wanted to
mention that there are times where
places can be unintentionally deceptive
in their
you know marketing and advertising um as
being a very safe place to go
and as cervi mentioned with her
experience with being followed i've been
through something
similar in japan and even in tokyo where
it's touted as one of the safest cities
in the world
and someone who's studied and lived
there for a while pickpockets stalkers
bad people in general live there too
and it's quite common for men to
sexually harass women on trains
which is why there are women-only cars
in the main train lines there
and i'd love to know what your thoughts
are about governments tours and bureaus
and their responsibility in being
transparent
and reminding tourists to be informed um
as well as tourists
reminding themselves to be informed
thanks for a great show and please
continue doing a great job
thanks anonymous that was a great
voicemail serbia that was
directly to you in a lot of ways
thoughts so
i am a big proponent of transparency and
i do think that
uh governments and um tour companies
should be more transparent but at the
end of the day it is the tourist
responsibility
um but i do find it a little sketchy
when i go to developing countries
and like things are are like hidden or
covered up and stuff so i would like
there to be more of a push on
um talking about things like uh
so i went to mexico and i found out that
a lot of those cenotes which are
like natural uh pools of water
and a lot of these cenotes have like
crocodiles in them
um but like tourists don't know that
and uh so i was talking to another girl
at the
place i was staying and she's like look
at these look at them look at them
and um she was showing me pictures and
then another place i was
uh touring these ruins and
apparently there are jaguars there and
so that's something i didn't know
and i think that there should be more
transparency but i think
uh it's always on us to keep ourselves
safe and we can't rely on other people
um i don't know i don't have anything
interesting to say on that but
i really enjoyed that voicemail is very
insightful
yeah that was awesome um no big
disagreements there
i think that's why i do like traveling
sometimes to cities because it's just
like more of a known quantity
whereas nature travel freaks me out and
there's a lot of different
films documentaries and like weird cable
series about disasters that happen when
people go
play around in nature that's too far out
of their comfort zone
yeah yeah um do we have any other
voicemails right now
uh no other voicemails okay uh alec let
us know we got going on
uh email-wise this time any hot messages
in the inbox
oh we got so many good messages uh yeah
the first one we've got an update
lawrence runs a sex club in australia
somewhere
i had a lot of questions about what
kovid's safe restrictions on sex
clubs are for obvious reasons lawrence
was great and emailed us back
hey culture bingers i was chuffed to
hear my email read out loud
i don't know what chuffed means but it
means just like like happy and pleased
nice uh
to answer your curiosities the
restrictions imposed on all sex clubs by
the new local
new south wales our government uh sorry
our state government essentially came
down to a venue capacity limit
of one person per four square meters
soon to be two square meters i hear
australia is
killing it on the not having a ton of
covid front
social distancing was not a restriction
imposed on us for our guest will
inside the menu in saying that it took
twice as long for sex clubs
to be allowed to trade than it did for
most other businesses where social
distancing was enforced
i suppose the government was waiting for
consistently low numbers in cases before
they allowed a high-risk business to
trade
that makes a lot of sense there were
other bits and pieces in our coveted
safe plan like having hand sanitizers
and
face mask available but after you've
been kissing someone new is hand
sanitizer really going to do anything
great question michael you're more than
welcome to come and slang some drinks at
the bar i would love to see your
superpowers
and what each person needs for a
post-coital drink oh i know making
friends thank you
getting on the first flight to australia
once that's allowed i'm showing up
with a cocktail shaker and some latex
gloves
and saying let's go i'm so excited
so that's so awesome thank you for
hanging back the sex club is called our
secret spot i believe
for those of you who are interested
sounds cool man
australia's i'm really jealous of
australia these days
for a lot of reasons but like in new
zealand they killed kovid
they can have concerts again they're
putting on theater productions
they have sex clubs just a lot going on
there's so much going on down there
down there
wow the next email is from connor
talking about uh women in sports uh
connor says i'm not a sports fan in the
slightest but i'm a big supporter of
equality
one thing that came to mind when you all
discussed women's sports was
professional wrestling in the
independent wrestling world
intergender wrestling is very common and
accepted the storylines and matches are
just as good if not better than regular
wrestling matches
what i find interesting is how the wwe
used to be alright with inter-gender
wrestling
but stopped once they got better tv
deals aew
a new wrestling organization that i'm a
fan of has lots of wrestlers that are
familiar with
inner gender wrestling and i believe are
adding it to their new game coming out
yeah i mean that sounds cool uh i know
one of our directors works for
an organization called party world
wrestling where i believe again it's
just like all kinds of people and it's
all fake so it doesn't matter who's
wrestling who it's not like
you know it's not like there's a
disadvantage
so interesting yeah um
yeah this just reminds me that i wish i
watched wrestling more i was really into
it when i was younger and whenever i
hear about wrestling i wish it was a
thing that i was more
into i didn't realize that it was fake
yeah what do you say fake what is what
does fake
mean like what do you do let's define
our terms here
like the w w
um i don't know what it's e you're yeah
you're compute because it used to be f
no i mean it's all i mean like yeah
they're like
you know throwing each other at [ __ ] and
like it's like physically punishing and
i'm not knocking it
but what is real you know like what's
what's
real if anything don't we just live in
one big simulation um
i mean it's cool i'm just saying i
thought it was real like like they were
actually like doing these things it
wasn't
scripted serbia what if there was a way
you could let yourself be deluded into
thinking it's real even when it's not
for the sake of your own entertainment
no i wish i could go back to those days
because it was fascinating i was like oh
my god
what if you could what if there was a
concept that could explain all this and
what if
wisecrack made a whole video about it
once that you could watch about a
concept called kfabe
look into it it's inspired music um man
i wish i
i wish i didn't tell serbi about this
and then like
somehow got her and watched her watch
donald trump in the wwe
and just like what would she think of
that like i don't even know the story
lines but like to think it's real would
add like another level
amazing so good um any other emails i
want to get into
just because yeah this last one is it's
a karen story uh from someone who's
concerned about some caring going on
um this person is from south africa
uh so there's gonna be different norms
with tipping and whatnot that i don't
understand
but here's the email my name is robin
from south africa and i've been a huge
fan of the wisecrack youtube channel
recently i listened to the rise of
karen's episode and have my own karen
story that's been bothering me lately i
was hoping to get your guys perspective
on it
a week ago was my friend's birthday and
a group of us celebrated at a popular
restaurant
and the service was horrible someone had
a scab in her drink i don't know
a scab is that slang for something
though i don't know
south africa don't understand your lingo
but scabbing the drink let's assume the
worst
our waitress kept forgetting to ring up
some of our orders the bartender
aggressively accused me of being poor
when my card kept declining
and i asked him to use a different card
machine which happened to work and my
card went
through suddenly changing his attitude
asking me about my day
our friends turned to my girlfriend and
asked her to please be a karen
and complain because she is super
assertive confident and takes no [ __ ]
she went to the manager on duty and gave
all of our complaints to which he
handled poorly and our service only got
worse we undertipped and the waitress
which really did feel bad
the next day we called the restaurant to
complain and got get more clarity about
the service the night before
to which the manager on duty to this day
said he will handle
the manager on duty this day said he
will handle it and would like to invite
the group back to make it up to us an
hour after that he messaged us
again to tell us he investigated the
waitress bartender manager and cameras
finding out that one of our group asked
the waitress if quote her legs were on
the menu
and that was the reason we shouldn't we
couldn't be given good service
the cameras also picked up the same
person did cocaine in the bathroom
before leaving it's for these reasons
that the restaurant
will not be apologetic about the service
and that we are not invited back
we queried our group on this and it
turns out that the person had been rude
to the waitress and did coke and
bathroom was our friend's dad's friend
friend's dad's friend popped up only
later in the evening to have one drink
after which
him and our friend's dad left not once
did the waitress or manager address
these issues with the table
even after the man had left and just
continued to treat us badly how do we
deal with this should we
be feeling bad about undertipping should
we feel guilty about complaining
when it was someone from our group
causing issues even though the service
was [ __ ] before they arrived is my
girlfriend karen for complaining on the
night and the next day
got so many layers to this i [ __ ]
love this email i want to like
draw out the web of relations to better
understand this
i mean a couple things i will say though
in one sense just at the top important
to note that
uh you know when we talk about someone
being a karen or whatever
that doesn't mean complaining as such as
a caring activity it means
complaining in an entitled way which
exceptionalizes your experience
over and above others because you know i
think all of us i i'm a great diner and
customer and i've occasionally been like
hey i'm sorry but
there's a blank in my blank and that
doesn't make you a caring or bad
i do think my personal stance on this is
that if you're with a group of people
and someone in the group is being an
[ __ ] if they're being reckless if
they're being at all verbally abusive to
staff or whatever
that's sadly still part of your
responsibility if you're a part of that
group
and your options rather you tell that
person to shut the [ __ ] up um i know
i've been out a couple times
in my younger years where there was a
dude in a group who was just a huge
douchebag
and i like got up found the server and
was like hey
i'm really sorry blah blah blah and like
gave them an extra tip or something like
that and just kind of said like
at least acknowledge that the situation
sucked i do that when i eat with my
grandparents they're so annoying and
then i go up to the server and i'm like
i'm really sorry they're old and they
complain too much here's some extra
money
don't hate me yeah um and it sounds like
in that situation that it's maybe a
mixture
but then i think so much of this
involves what scab means in a south
african context if it means
congealed dried blood on the surface of
the skin
then all that's already taken out her
headphones everyone
but then part of me thinks maybe it's
you can come back part of me thinks that
maybe is like
you know if it's like slaying for like a
roofie or something then like you should
not be okay with someone putting a scab
in your drink
um um i'm googling it i think that
everyone is justified
the group handled it fine i think that
everything was fine on their end i think
that the
problem here is the restaurant should
have discussed these issues
with the group as soon as the
friend's dad's friend
i don't know if i agree with that well
go ahead sorry you finished your thought
i think that the friend's dad's friend
as soon as he harassed the waitress the
manager should have come over and either
asked the group to leave or told him
you know to knock it off um or served
the t
the the group personally um i also think
that like the cocaine in the bathroom
situation like again why didn't the
restaurant leave
um i mean why didn't the restaurant ask
the group to leave um
but the the service was bad before that
guy even showed up
so it seems like it's an excuse but i
don't think there was a problem about
complaining
or under tipping yeah i think
well my take on i think the manager
thing you're right about i don't even
think about that possibility but like i
feel like it's not on the waitress
for instance who has been sexually
harassed to be like hey
excuse me i know one of you just
sexually harassed me but like it's now
my
job to like inform you all that like
this person because like they're
probably oh no i would never expect that
yeah but then i
like having the manager come in um i
think that that's that's pretty
reasonable
um it seems like there was some other
loki issues that maybe they
they dismissed because the the service
what was you know if the service was bad
before and stuff like that
um maybe it's all getting lumped in
there so
i don't know there's subreddit called am
i the [ __ ] and there's uh
there's like an answer that's like
everyone's an [ __ ] here and that
might not that you're an [ __ ] robin
for for having
the friends shitty dad friend and like
as someone who used to wait tables
i was at times able to differentiate
between like the one rowdy [ __ ] but
at the same time like
you brought them and like i know that
you don't know this friend of a friend
but
i don't know it's if i was with someone
super embarrassing it's it's partially
on me like it's on me when my
grandparents are being in the pain they
asked to
you know try to limit that or rectify
that or anything like that not to say
you could have known that they
they did this thing but it's a
reasonable kind of expectation
and if nothing else um never go back
there unless your town has one bar
and restaurant establishment i just
don't see a world where
you are ever going to be wanted there or
were you ever going to enjoy yourself
there
so i'd say maybe cut your losses take
the l and find a new regular spot and
never invite your dad's friends around
again they sound [ __ ] terrible
yeah what do you guys think about the
tipping
i think service was bad so and like she
had like some weird thing in her drink
and all this like weird [ __ ] going on
like yeah but here's the thing right
i've had times before
there's something wrong with my food but
like this the person working in the
kitchen
is getting like a flat hourly rate and
the person serving me is largely working
off tips
and it sucks for them but it's not their
fault if you know
sally in the kitchen let a booger fall
in my pastrami sandwich
so i don't want to punish the server for
something that's not
their fault yeah i wish we could
separate
um separate like tips because sometimes
like the food is awesome
but the server is like super rude and
mean to me
it makes me feel bad about my food
allergies so i would like to then be
like
i will give the kitchen this tip
but you get less of a tip because you
were an [ __ ] just everyone should get
paid a good
well yeah this is why tipping is the
problem like we should tip and tip
generously especially right now when the
restaurant industry is falling apart
but the solution of course is a system
where tipping is a necessity there's a
flat service fee incurred and everyone
working there gets a flat
rate rather than working off tips so we
don't have to feel the individual
pressure
to tip well so that someone can pay
their rent i mean this was my argument
we agree with you we agree with your
argument but not the
i think the problem with your argument
is i agree with it in general serbia but
that means
in the interim i still got to tip as
much as i can yeah well
until that happens we know we do do we
just give you [ __ ] we just give you [ __ ]
we know
no because we're getting emails where
people are like oh she seems like her
okay let's say this once and for all
serbia always tips a flat 11 no matter
what
she's on top of things she takes care of
you if you see her in your establishment
expect the best maybe so up to 13 if you
wink at her
um so okay we probably should wrap up
though unless there's any final thoughts
on this one
just one final thought i don't know the
the economic situation of tipping south
africa i quickly googled it which seems
it's like america
uh except it's only expected to tip 10
percent so oh sorry
if they have good wages and tipping
truly is extra like that's a different
game like maybe maybe don't but
i don't know the thing about boogers
scabs hairs in your food obviously it's
bad obviously you're right to be like
hey can you make me another one or
something
but like these are unavoidable
accidents of like humans interacting
with food is just like
[ __ ] gets into it and it's not like i
mean absent
i have no reason to believe the server
was like i'm gonna take the scab and put
in their food
and so like basically at that point
you're just penalizing a person for like
a very unavoidable thing
uh that they had no control over and
it's not like every waiter that you've
ever seen like meticulously checks all
your ice cubes to make sure there's
nothing weird in it
they're just like running between ten
tables and so for that i would not
necessarily
tip less i would say
the rare occasion that i took just 15 is
like
something went wrong and they refused
and i was like hey we've been waiting
for our food for an hour
and they'd like don't do anything
they're they're not like
oh i'll check on that or i'm so sorry
they're just like yeah whatever like
allow them to rectify the thing keep
their tips high but then like if they're
completely
not helping you at all fine okay
that's the final word on that one great
email great emails as always and of
course uh
just so you know this all of your emails
are great we sadly can't get into all of
them every time but please don't take
not having your email right as an
indication that we don't love and
appreciate it i recently just got added
to our email thing so now i can see them
all and i'm obsessed with it it's so
great
um so do hit us up once again culture
binge wisecrack.com
or 213-534-8807 and of course if you
like this let us know if you'd like us
to do an
all email advice episode which i want to
do and if enough of you tell
us you want it maybe we can do it and
then a final thing
um and also we will not be around in two
weeks but if you're interested meeting
up with us
we might be doing a special charity
stream the week of christmas
so you can check in um see what's up uh
alec and i might be doing
stuff on there talking some philosophy
playing some games maybe some other
special guests will come on we'll ask
them later
um that said before we finally go we've
been going for a real long time
if people want to find you when you're
not here serbia where do they find you
digitally sorry patel 22
on twitter awesome alec where can they
find you that's not at the
local bodega at wisecrack alec
awesome um you can find me at michael o
burns we'll be back in the new year
might you want to stream in the meantime
email call rate review subscribe and
love yourself
see you next time
[Music]
you